how much worse is the base model Bend M3
Max with a 14 core CPU and 30 core GPU
compared to the one that Apple
advertised the full 16 core and 40 core
GPU because this year they made it $500
more expensive because when you try to
upgrade the chip to 16 cores they force
you to get 48 GB of RAM of $500 upgrade
so in this video I'm going to be doing a
bunch of performance tests to find out
and I'm actually going to comparing the
battery life because they're both at
100% so I'm going to unplug them and see
if that better CPU uses more battery
life so let's start off with geek
bench's CPU test both of these are at
4.05 GHz in high power mode and look at
that for the extra $500 we're getting a
10.6% faster multicore score you be the
judge of whether it's worth it or not
but of course this is just geekbench
I'll show you in the real world tests
what you should really expect but now
the graphics is where we should be
seeing an even bigger difference because
the 40 core version of the N3 Max has
33% more cores than the 30 core so let's
go ahead and test the metal test and
would you look at that we're looking at
only a
26% difference in geekbench that
actually doesn't really seem worth it
and now let's get into web design
performance with a project sent To Us by
500 designs over in California a really
good web design studio the first test is
going to be kind of zooming in and
seeing how fast it loads the information
and look at that basically perfectly
sharp right away super quick and then on
the other
one huh looks like that one actually
seemed to take a little bit longer but
the main test is to export these 12
layers and see how long it takes and
surprisingly they both finish in exactly
a minute and 26 seconds so really for
web design there's no point to upgrade
to the unb ship and now let's do a more
real world gaming Benchmark this is 3D
Marks Wildlife extreme which is going to
simulate a gaming performance workload
so let's start this and wow look at that
143.5 fps to
188.000 that's
31% higher that is actually a huge
difference for $500 extra dollars
especially in the gaming world all you
Gamers know that's a big upgrade
especially since you also get the extra
Ram as well and now let's get into
blender 3D rendering performance because
the biggest change with these new M3
chips is the new Ray tracing cores so
I'm curious to see if the ray tracing
does most of the work and maybe the
actual difference in GPU count doesn't
matter that much but before we get into
that I've got to show you guys a couple
of awesome new products from our sponsor
vessie this right here is the brand new
Ulta high top sneaker which is perfect
for winter because it's water waterproof
all the way up to the top built with
both vegan leather and vess's unique
diamex knit material to keep your feet
dry and comfy no matter the conditions
it's got excellent grip on the bottom
and it comes in three colors black white
and dune beige now these right here are
vess's waterproof gloves and yes they're
made out of the same diamex nit material
which sounds impossible but it actually
works they're soft stretchy and comfy
keeping your hands completely dry and
warm together with the Ulta high top
sneaker it's the perfect combo for
winter and if you don't get any snow
where you're at they've also got a bunch
of other options like their overcast
jacket and Soho sneaker all waterproof
and you can order any of them today by
using the link below to get vess's best
sale of the year and wow would you look
at that guys 28.5 seconds on the full 40
core M3 Max
31.5 seconds for the bend model even
with the extra Ram that is basically
used as vram with these Apple silicon
chips only a couple of seconds faster
that means this bin model is perfectly
good for 3D rendering you should not
upgrade to the full model that's
actually very surprising and now let's
move on to some real world CPU based
tasks because this model does have 16
cores with 12 performance cores compared
to the 14 core model here which only has
10 performance cores so let's see which
one does better for music production in
logic pro now the main point of this
test is to see the kind of stress load
that both of them can handle as you can
see this one has already overloaded and
stopped the test it can't handle 328
tracks but this one is going just fine
let's try 310 nope not 310 and wow guys
there is a big difference the 14 core
model can only handle
275 tracks compared to
328 on the 16 core model obviously
that's already a lot for both of these
but this gives you a good sense of how
much more it can handle with the 16 core
and now let's test programming
performance in the X code 15 Benchmark
which has been reworked to take longer
so all the other scores no longer match
up but this one's going to be
interesting because we do also have that
Ram difference 48 gigs compared to 36
and it looks like we have 79 seconds for
the 14 core M3 Max and
72.5 for the 16 core definitely faster
but not that big of a difference
especially with the extra Ram so even an
xcode I don't even think it's worth
upgrading and now let's move on to
cinebench 2024 but unlike usual where I
do the CPU test first I'm actually going
to do the GPU test just one run to see
what difference we get here now what's
interesting is that the GPU usage on the
40 core M3 Max peaked at around 33 Watts
while the 30 core peaked at around
25.5 Watts that's basically
29.4% more power usage to give us a
score that is 25
5.2% faster
12,654 points compared to 10,102 that's
actually pretty decent scaling in terms
of GPU wattage and now let's switch over
to the 10-minute throttling test for the
multicore CPU performance and wow the
power usage as well this thing's going
up to what 54 53 54 Watts while the
other one is only at around 45 Watts
both of them are now stuck at 100
102° C it looks like that's kind of the
cap for these chips but I did notice a
little bit of throttling on the 16 core
M3 Max because you could see the
performance core clock it went down to
3.54
3.53 but this one actually is stuck flat
at 3.58 which is the maximum and the
other one is throttling just a little
bit and just like that we are now maxing
out the fans on the 16 core model while
well only around Midway halfway there on
the 14 core model and I'm hearing all of
the fan noise from the right side right
now so it looks like those extra two
performance cores are very very taxing
in terms of multicore load but
thankfully it's keeping the temps in
check because we are now running at flat
3.58 GHz clock speed no throttling at
all it's able to keep up the performance
but on the other hand I'm not hearing
fan noise from the left side it's still
at about halfway to the max here so
definitely so much less fan noise under
full 100% load it's been about 5 minutes
into this test and the fans are actually
slowing down on this 16 core model so
it's actually able to keep it in check
now it's reducing the fan noise which is
actually very reassuring and I'm really
curious to see with this thermal camera
what we're going to see in terms of the
surface Tech
all right over here on the 14 core M3
Max we're looking at about
36° C right where the chip is at and on
the display look at that 40° C so it's
getting rid of that heat very
efficiently now moving over to the 16
core interesting the hot spot where the
chip is at is only 33° C that's probably
because it really had to kick up those
fans get rid of the Heat and the hot
spot also 36 6° C so lower temps on this
one because it had to kick those fans up
so high and now that the fan speed has
finally slowed down on the 16 core model
about halfway on each side the 14 core
actually slowed down even more and I'm
still hearing almost all the fan noise
on the right side so this thing so far
is King at least for the fan noise let's
wait for these scores and there you go
we have our scores 1597 on the 16 core
and
1371 on the 14 core that makes it
16.5% faster in multicore performance
which is actually a pretty impressive
difference and now let's get into photo
editing performance with Lightroom
classic as you can see I have 50 raw 42
megapixel images here and switching
between them they're both just as quick
even with the extra RAM on the 16 core
model they're both very very snpp
loading images at the same time so what
I'm going to do is export these 50
photos and see the difference in export
speeds and by the way this test is
actually maxing out the CPU and the GPU
at the same time so this one's going to
get an even bigger Advantage but wait a
minute they just finished the six new
core model got 30 seconds which is
mind-blowingly Fast and the 14 core
model did it in
34.5 seconds also go very very fast but
obviously just a little bit slower
honestly guys I'm starting to get very
very impressed by this bin model that's
$500 less expensive and now let's get
into video editing performance with
Final Cut Pro this is a 5minute project
of 4K footage in the most common format
that people shoot and edit in which is
now
h.265 or hvc as you can tell we're
getting perfect 24 FPS playback on both
of them so let's export and yep just as
expected they both finish at exactly the
same time a minute and 13 seconds and
that's of course because they both have
the same hvc encoders so it's limited by
that so because of that we got to test
something that doesn't rely on the
encoders or at least isn't limited by
them so this is Canon R5 footage 8K in a
4K timeline so let's do a playback test
seeing which one kind of plays it back
more smoothly there you go there it is
now that they hit
102° this thing is now throttling
seemingly slowing down and it's not
playing back as smooth wait a minute the
16 core is doing the same thing it's
also playing back slower and they're
actually both ramping up at the same
time both maxed out fans they're both
heating up like mad because this is a
CPU and GPU workload at the same time
however I am looking on the right side
and it's still more smooth look at that
definitely more smooth than the 14 core
model so I let them cool down let's do
the export and see and there you go the
test just finished the fans are blasting
off like crazy but there's not that big
of a difference guys 4 minutes and 48
seconds for the 16 core model and 5
minutes and 8 seconds for the 14 core
that's only 20 seconds longer in the
grand scheme of things probably because
this thing was thermal throttling a
little bit because it just fully
blasting the CPU and GPU this is by the
way the biggest workload that we can
find that Maxes everything out for video
editing wow it's not that big of a
difference and now with all that said
and tested it's time for my honest
opinion on which one of these you should
buy but first we got to take a look at
the battery life looks like we have 41%
on this Bend model
46% on the 16 core M3 Max so there's a
little bit of a difference I don't know
why because this thing probably should
be using more power maybe it's a margin
of error or a testing kind of thing but
not that big of a difference based on
everything that I've seen in this video
with everything I've compared on see
guys save your cash just stick with the
bend model save your $500 spend that
somewhere else so hopefully you guys
enjoy this video and if you did
subscribe above for more videos like
this one definitely check out one of
those two right there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
one